well here we are entering tax season and
many things will be a little different
this time around here to help you get
ready to file is mark stieber chief tax
information officer at jackson hewitt
good morning mark it's so nice to have
you with us i really appreciate it
uh all right so we're getting ready to
do our 2021 taxes what's the biggest
change taxpayers need to know about for
this tax season
well the biggest change is the change
that impacts your taxes and your refund
and there's a lot to pick from for folks
this year there were changes to
unemployment benefits taxation
charitable deduction donations even if
you don't itemize there were changes to
the earned income credit there were
changes to dependent care credit if you
have kids in daycare or summer camp but
the single largest one affects millions
of families that have young children
they've supersized the child tax credit
used to be it was a nice two thousand or
fourteen hundred dollar credit this year
for 2021 it is a maximum of three
thousand six hundred dollars per child
on your tax return with no limit on that
and that's for the younger children
older children are three thousand and
even high income earners who don't
qualify for that you know can get two
thousand if they earn up to four hundred
thousand if they're married or two
thousand if they're if they're single so
the long story short child tax credit
for anyone with a child dependent on
their tax return could not be more
important to confuse matters worse
though the irs started paying up to half
the benefit early back in
july of 2021 so taxpayers may receive up
to six advanced payments for half their
advanced child tax credit they'll have
to file the credit correctly to get the
other half and then pile on top of that
any new dependents that happen to be on
their taxes because they were born or
adopted or fostered in 2021 or just
shared custody that rolls on in 2021.
all of those will get the full amount of
that child credit in 2021. oh my
goodness all right so there's got to be
documentation i assume we're getting
letters from the irs that documents all
of this
that all needs to be filed is that right
and what other documents are really
important
yeah there'll be a tsunami of paperwork
this year if i don't use the word uh
just because people are having more w-2s
many people work multi-jobs they'll get
a w-2 for that just like always but more
of them 1099s for interest and dividend
there'll be statements not government or
broker statements but stuff related to
your virtual currency that's gotten more
important than ever to watch for those
there'll be statements related to health
care that's still required there'll be
statements for unemployment benefits was
tax exempt now it's back to taxable
you'll need to watch for that and then
there's two new documents to watch for
there was a stimulus payment the third
one seemed like years ago for that third
stimulus payment back in march of 2021
you'll get a statement for that and if
you've got new dependents like i talked
about a moment ago for child credit you
may have new stimulus money that's yours
you'll need that stimulus money letter
to reconcile for that you'll have a
child tax credit letter if you wanted
the 35 million that got advanced
payments you'll importantly need that
document because it has how much you've
got where it went direct deposit or in
the mail how many children were on your
you know estimate that they made and
you'll reconcile that on your 2021
return to get the other half plus any
new ones so just a barrage of paperwork
and the important point to remember is
simply this if you're not accurate and i
mean your data matches the irs data
you'll set yourself up for a week's or
months delay like about 30 million
people had last year so accuracy has a
new important point to consider you just
won't get your money for months so pay
attention to those documents collect
them in the shoe box share them with
your tax pro file early and get your big
refund faster oh my goodness i think
tsunami was a perfect word barrage
tsunami all of those are accurate well
let's talk about working at home because
so many people have done that if you
have a home office is it tax deductible
great question an area just like some of
these other unemployment benefits and
credits very confusing the home office
is a deduction that's been around for
decades it's a great tax benefit
unfortunately with the super sizing of
the american public working from home
within many cases a office at home with
a desk a chair a phone a computer you
know they have a home office so it
sounds pretty simple there's a tax form
home office deduction unfortunately the
confusion is simply this if you're an
employee working for a company and
you're working at home for the
convenience of the employer or out of an
abundance of caution or they just closed
your office as many have and so you're
working from home not by choice you
unfortunately do not generally qualify
for the home office deduction on the
other hand if you have a home office
based business self-employed or
full-time you know etsy or
amazon that would in fact meet the
qualifying criteria some of the
confusion comes from the fact that i
just said if you're an employee you
don't get it well if you're an employee
with a side business or a spouse perhaps
that has a side-based business or for a
part-time business out of the home then
you're back in the yes category so know
if you're pure employee but yes if you
have any kind of home-based activity and
i encourage people to look at that one
because it is a very nice benefit it's a
simple model and complex model that can
really cut your costs increase your tax
deduction and frankly increase your
refund and help offset some of that
other stuff that may be penalizing you
on your startup business no home office
no employee yes if your home
office-based business gotcha so the w-2
really makes the difference there right
you're getting paid by an employer and
you're working at home it doesn't count
okay and it's easy to catch so if you
put it on there and you're one of these
adventurous do-it-yourselvers and you're
gonna put the home office deduction and
the software lets you if there's not a
schedule c for self-employment just the
home office deduction you're gonna get
caught pretty quick oh boy did we cover
unemployment
a lot of taxpayers collected
unemployment
okay yeah that's unfortunately some of
the bad news i pointed out all the new
great benefits and credits unemployment
both confusing and not good it was not
taxable in tax year 2020 because of a
late law change unfortunately that was
2020 only in 2021 it's back to full
taxable so you'll probably get a 1099 g
and even if you don't it's still taxable
it goes on your tax return if you leave
it off the irs will find out and they
will send you a letter so in short
unemployment benefits back to taxable
unfortunate though it is for 2021. oh
boy there was a lot of that as well well
thank you mark steverboy you're a wealth
of knowledge and information we
appreciate it so much
i think finding somebody to do our taxes
this year might be a good idea with all
of that facing us we appreciate it no
it's going to be a busy season for you
appreciate your time thank you
all good have a great day you too